lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
darte una demostración convincente de la
regla del producto para derivadas así
que empecemos realmente con la
definición de derivada muy bien
recordemos que si nosotros tenemos por
ejemplo una función f x y digamos que
esta función es derivable es decir
podemos obtener la derivada de esta
función esto por definición verdad así
se define la derivada es el límite
cuando h tiende a cero de fx + h - f x
dividido entre h muy bien y por supuesto
decimos que la función es derivables y
este límite existe verdad y visualmente
lo que nos dice este límite es que
podemos calcular la pendiente de la
recta tangente a la gráfica en el punto
x verdad así que ahora vamos a hacer
algo más interesante digamos que tenemos
o más bien que queremos calcular
derivada de uno de fx sino de fx por g
de x es decir queremos calcular la
derivada del producto de dos funciones
muy bien ese será nuestro objetivo en
este vídeo y como tenemos aquí la
definición pues podemos simplemente
utilizar la verdad esto sería el límite
cuando h tiende a cero y aquí voy a
dejar un una línea muy muy muy muy
grande que vamos a poner una línea muy
grande porque bueno ya ya veras porque
vamos a utilizar esta línea grande pero
tenemos abajo h muy bien ya arriba
tenemos la función que en este caso es f
x por gd x evaluada en x + h entonces en
este caso tenemos f de x + h x
de x + h verdad esto sería esta primera
parte en nuestra definición y luego
restamos la función evaluada en x verdad
que en este caso serían menos f x x gdx
pero lo voy a poner más acá de hecho voy
a extender un poco más la línea y vamos
entonces a poner menos f x por gd x muy
bien y entonces tú te estarás
preguntando bueno y porque dejo todo
este espacio tan raro en esta en esta
fracción verdad y ahorita vamos vas a
darte cuenta por qué
en realidad si nosotros observamos nada
más esta expresión pues realmente no hay
como mucha facilidad de cómo trabajarlo
algebraica mente verdad entonces no nos
da ninguna idea de cómo podríamos
obtener una fórmula para la derivada del
producto de dos funciones muy bien así
que de hecho aquí viene un truco verdad
ya mí a lo mejor no se me hubiera
ocurrido a menos de que ya estuviera no
sé a lo mejor toda una tarde observando
el problema o quizás después de tres
días de intentarlo se me hubiera
ocurrido pero lo que sí es cierto es que
a alguien ya se le había ocurrido sumar
y restar algo verdad sumamos algo y
restamos ese mismo algo para que no se
afecte esta expresión verdad y entonces
con esa cosa que sumemos podemos
manipular algebraica mente esta
expresión y lo que hay que restar por
ejemplo podríamos restar
efe de x + h
gx pero si lo restamos hay que sumarlo
fx más h por gd x muy bien entonces
restamos y sumamos esto y entonces
realmente estamos no estamos modificando
esta expresión pero ahora ya podemos
manipular algebraica mente este límite
muy bien entonces vamos vamos a
continuar con con esto
y aquí por supuesto habría que mencionar
que f y g son derivables verdad si no a
lo mejor podría no tener sentido
calcular esta derivada aunque vamos a
suponer que fije son derivables y
continuemos eso será importante al final
del vídeo ahora tomamos el límite cuando
h tiende a cero y aquí es en donde vamos
a poder manipular esta verdad primero
tomamos esta expresión o esta parte de
la expresión ok aquí tenemos esta parte
de la expresión y podemos observar que
podemos factorizar un f x + h
fx más h lo podemos factorizar verdad
entonces escribimos efe de x + h que
multiplica a lo que nos resta que sería
x + h menos gdx dividido todo eso entre
h muy bien aquí esto es simplemente esta
expresión que tenemos circulada en em en
azul digamos muy bien y ahora podemos
considerar la otra parte de la expresión
verdad recuerden que h divide a todo
entonces también divide esta parte de la
expresión y eso simplemente sería lo
siguiente tenemos ahora que podemos
factorizar gx verdad podemos factorizar
que de x y que nos queda tenemos gdx que
multiplica a efe de x + h - efe de x /
todo esto también entre h y hay que
sacar el límite de toda esta expresión y
ahora lo único que necesitamos es
acordarnos de las propiedades del límite
verdad porque aquí tenemos una suma de
esta expresión con esta otra expresión y
el límite de una suma es
zuma de los límites ahora bien por
ejemplo aquí tenemos una expresión por
esta otra expresión a la cual habrá que
sacarle el límite entonces el límite de
un producto es el producto de los
límites muy bien vamos a vamos a
expresar esto simplemente esto sería el
límite cuando h tiende a cero de f de x
+ h
por el límite del límite
cambia de verde
ponerlo bien por el límite cuando h
tiende a ser hoy aquí no parece h ahora
sí de gd x más h - g de x - g x y todo
eso dividido entre h y yo creo que ya te
estarás dando cuenta a dónde vamos a
llegar verdad entonces déjenme poner
paréntesis sería este producto más
verdad hay que sacar el límite de las
sumas perdón el límite de la suma es la
suma de los límites entonces sería el
límite de este producto que es el
producto de los límites sería límite
cuando h tiende a cero deje de x gx por
el límite cuando h tiende a cero de fx
más h
ops debería usar el mismo color vamos a
usar el mismo color
sería fx más h
- efe de x todo eso / / h verdad
entonces sacamos el límite de esto bueno
más bien sería este límite que
multiplica a este otro límite y ahora
vamos a ver qué es cada uno de esos
límites verdad hasta ahorita sólo hemos
utilizado las las propiedades de los
límites entonces si nos fijamos por
ejemplo en este primer límite si tenemos
fx + h y aplicamos el límite cuando h h
tiende a 0 nos gustaría mucho decir que
esto es f x verdad y eso sí pasa por la
razón que dijimos al inicio
efe que son funciones derivables y en un
vídeo anterior vimos que f es derivable
sí e implica que es continua verdad si
tenemos una función derivable entonces
es continua y entonces este límite si es
f x muy bien ahora qué pasaría con esta
expresión que tenemos aquí que nos voy a
poner quizás con
este color rosa entonces esto de aquí es
justo la definición de la derivada
verdad es justamente lo que tenemos aquí
arriba eso quiere decir que esto es la
derivada de g y es el límite existe
porque supusimos que la que era
derivable verdad y ahora sumamos sumamos
el límite cuando h tiende a 0 de g de x
eso simplemente es que de x porque nada
depende de la h
y de este otro lado podríamos ponerlo
bueno en supuesta verdad y del otro lado
tenemos esta expresión que nuevamente
coincide con la definición de la
derivada entonces esto simplemente sería
la derivada de f entonces vamos a
escribir lo más bonito esto simplemente
obtuvimos que era f x porque prima de x
es decir la derivada de g
gx gx por efe prima de g
por f prima de x o la derivada de f
verdad entonces como a mucha gente le
gusta decir que sería lo siguiente que
la derivada de un producto de dos
funciones sería la primera función por
la derivada de la segunda más la segunda
por la derivada de la primera y esto
sólo fue una demostración verdad tal vez
puede haber otras pruebas de la regla
del producto pero esta es una
demostración muy directa muy bonita y
además es fácil de entender